morning
so today is
the second tutorial on sparse random
graphs
uh
let me
first start with in the first five
minutes or so
start with what we covered last day
uh
so last day
we
looked at a basic model random graph at
the sweeney random graph where you had n
vertices and each edge is connected with
probability lambda over n and this model
has a phase transition at lambda equals
1.
and
our main
tool was to study relationship between
exploring this graph in a breadth first
manner and a branching process
uh
we showed that first of all the
exploration can be upper bounded uh by a
poisson lambda branching process
uh so if lambda is less than one this
poisson lambda branching process is
sub-critical you can use it to upper
bound the component sizes
we showed
a more general result like maximum
component sizes
are of order log n but we did not really
prove it but this
shows that you have microscopic
components if lambda is less than one
and the second half we spend proving the
supercritical phase so if lambda is more
than one then the branching process
survives and in that case we have this
result so let's see i be the eighth
largest component of the dossier number
and if lambda is more than one
then the proportion of vertices in the
largest component converges to zeta
lambda where zeta lambda is the survival
probability of a poisson branching
process
uh if lambda is more than one branching
for the survives right so this is
positive
and the proportion of vertices in the
second largest component
is
going to zero that's asymptotically
negligible with high probability
well
we
did a proof of this and there were two
factors in the proof
that were important
first was local neighborhood
approximation we said that if we start
exploring the graph from a random vertex
uniformly chosen u then the local
neighborhood
is approximated by a branching process
with high probability so when the
branching process survives the
component is large
so that was the first ingredient
and the second ingredient was if we you
choose two random vertices and their
component size is large then they have
to intersect they cannot be in different
components
okay
so
this proof
we showed is quite general so if you
have other random graph models where you
can verify these two conditions then you
can get the same result here okay
so
how did we verify this for uh at the
random graph well we started growing two
neighborhoods from u1 and u2 and showed
that after some time these neighborhoods
grow exponentially and when these
neighborhoods have
psi square root n they intersect
therefore they have to be in the same
component
okay so that was the recap
so today
i'll be talking introducing first some
other model that's a more realistic
model with more realistic features some
of them you have been already seeing in
other talks
in this part i will introduce
the first models that was introduced
to capture these realistic features
summarize the results will not do all
the proofs uh proofs can be done using
this technique so you can verify these
techniques i will mostly focus on
getting the local neighborhood
approximation that's it not verify the
second condition for this new random
graph
and in the second part i
want to tell you about percolation and
epidemics in particular i will try to
tell you about a very general result
that works for epidemics on that is
working on a general finite network
okay
so that's coming up
finally if we have time
uh
i will briefly tell you about a
fascinating technique in random graph
theory that uses stochastic process
convergence to conclude about
convergence of component sizes so this
technique is really interesting uh hope
i get time to do this
okay
let me say again if you have any
questions in between please feel free to
interrupt okay
all right uh let's start by looking at a
few random graph model with
more realistic features
so what are the
other realistic features that occur in
real world networks okay there are
usually community structures in the
network right
people in same community get to connect
with each other with higher probability
than between different communities and
also the degree distribution is usually
heterogeneous meaning that they are
usually heavy tail the degree
distribution
and most often also the graphs are
evolving with time
if you look at social networks people
are joining all the time in the social
network these are growing networks
so
the first model
one of the first models to capture this
kind of things
were stochastic block model uh
configuration model and preferential
attachment model uh these are not
necessarily the most complex models
these are actually the simplest models
that capture these features
so
uh let me start with the stochastic
block model
so this is the model with global
community structure uh usually this is
popular very much in cs and machine
learning literature for the community
detection problems
okay
so
but we will not do communication we will
do the giant component today
so what is the model description
we have k greater than equal to two
communities
uh and size of each community we will
denote that by ni
and we will assume that proportion of
vertices in each of the communities is
converging to rho i where some y is some
positive number
so each of these parts you are seeing
is large they scale
linearly with the network size
and number two is edges between say
two vertices in different communities
arrive
with probability p i j over n and in in
the same community they occur with uh p
i i over n so you have a probability
matrix
that captures the connectivity between
different communities
so this divided by n is to make this
graph sparse
okay
and we'll throw out assume that
p i j is strictly between 0 and 1
otherwise there can be trivial examples
right because if p i j equals zero two
communities can be completely
disconnected and so on
uh so we'll assume p i j is strictly
between zero and one
okay
to find the giant component the local
neighborhood approximation is super
important let's do the local
neighborhood approximation of stochastic
block model right
so
we start with a random vertex uniformly
chosen
and the random vertex
what is the
let's say
in which community does the random
vertex fall well it will fall in the ith
community
with probability
n i over n right because that's the ith
community size which is by our
assumption approximately equal to rho i
so if we choose a uniform vertex the
first vertex would be from community i
with
probability rho i
if you take n tends to infinity
we are doing branching plus
approximation right so we will take n to
infinity
okay so uniform vertex in community i uh
so
it
appears with probability rho i in the
beginning
and what is the neighborhood
distribution well if we have k
communities
uh a vertex in say community i will have
binomial
in j
comma
p i j
over n many neighbors in the jth
community right
it has approximately this many neighbors
because each connections are independent
well if i equals j you have to subtract
1 but let's not worry about that
so
the mean is approximately
nj
times pij over n
well n n j over n equals
rho j so this is approximately equals to
rho j times p i j
and these are binomial binomials at the
n tends to infinity limit this will
become poisson
so at the next step you will
get vertices of
different communities represented by
different colors
and
the what is
there will be poisson row jpi j many
vertices in the next step from community
j
so this is our local neighborhood
approximation and in the next step this
will have further progeny but the
distribution of progeny of this red
vertex is different from distribution of
progeny of the blue vertex right
because
they have different connection
probabilities to other
vertices
so this is
not the usual type of branching process
that i
told you about last day so these things
are called
multi-type branching processes and also
there is a theory of studying multi-type
branching processes
uh
for that uh let's look at the mean
matrix p i j star which is rho j times p
i j
and let lambda 1 p star with the largest
eigen value of p star
okay
so assume that this
so this has positive entries so
the lambda 1 p star is positive by
parent permanence theorem
now
a fact coming from multi-type branching
processes
is that
this branching process will survive
if the largest eigenvalue of this p star
matrix
is more than one it will die out if this
is less than one okay
now we have the branching process
approximation we know when the
approximation survives
or
dies out so we know can you give us some
intuition by the largest eigenvalue
should come in
uh
so
so basically it comes out of a
martingale argument uh so
if you look at the mean matrix
uh
yeah so you iteratively take powers of
the mean matrix right at the nth
generation uh the mean would be m to the
power n
so that
i mean so what you're saying is that if
i start if it's generation
t i have
an alpha vertices of color alpha
then the expected number of purchases of
color better is
than alpha times p star alpha beta prime
yes expected number of vertices
involves the powers of people and
actually if the large sign value is
smaller than one it dies
not just otherwise exactly
thank you
so this is the condition of our giant
emergence so here is the result just for
sake of bookkeeping
we know that lambda 1 p star is less
than 1 means subcritical lambda 1 p
start more than one super critical for
stochastic block model so
i will end here actually for stochastic
block model because i will cover other
models as well but uh ah
just wanted to mention there is a more
challenging uh model and more general
model actually that is currently
considered in the foundational work of
bolobus johnson and rewarden in that
case you can have
infinitely many types even uncountably
many times obviously dealing with them
is a super challenging task operator
norms show up but
if you are interested in finding more
general uh inhomogeneous random graphs
then stochastic block model check out
this paper
okay
here's their nice closed form for the
size of the dragon component when you
have a stochastic cloth model
well you can again use this trick right
so you can use the fixed point equation
okay
so
it will satisfy
this equation problem let me try to
write
1 minus theta
yes
so it is actually a vector i mean in the
general case it is a function
so zeta i
so
survives starting from i
is one this probability is
no
there satisfies not 1 minus
you have e to the power minus
p star matrix
and then
so from that you can compute the zeta
and you can
uh take the mean of that
mean of this data i that will
give you this theta okay so that first
thing is a vector of once then oh i see
so i haven't here so that's why it's
confusing for you so let's say this is
the tilde this is a vector
okay
so i mean essentially you can do the
same trick right so you can say that it
survives if all its progeny survives
that's how you get the fixed publication
okay
next up
models for degree heterogeneous networks
so this kind of networks occur quite
often in real world networks and you can
see that there are vertices in the
network which has really really high
degree compared to this vertices for
example
and
so such degree heterogeneous networks
with hubs or celebrities are common
occurrence
and there are debates on what the degree
distributions are yeah some people say
it's a power law some people say it's a
truncated power law but one thing is for
certain these are definitely not poisson
right
so you cannot model them with education
uh
so we need a simple and analytically
tractable model to study degree
heterogeneous networks
and for that we will introduce
this configuration model which gives you
a way to generate graphs with any degree
sequence basically
okay
all right uh
what is the model uh
suppose you are you are given a degree
sequence d1 due to dn
and
you start out with half edges attached
to each of the vertices so these half
edges are potential edges that will be
created right uh so
from the ith vertex you always get d i
many half edges
so the ith vertex always has degree d i
we want to keep the degree fixed
so start with bi many half edges that is
attached to vertex i
and then you can pair the half edges
uniformly at random so you take this
vertex pair it uniformly at random with
another one keep repeating the same
trick you always
take any half edge
then uniformly pair it with another the
choice of the first half edge
does not matter quite much in the
distribution sense
but
you can play this game
and at the end you end up with a graph
with a given degree sequence
of course
i have
not tell told you about one thing it can
happen that
multiple edges could occur in this graph
right or self loops could occur it could
be that you pair two half edges that is
associated to the same vertex or
you pair like
four half edges that are associated to
two vertices so those kind of situations
of course can occur so at the end you
will in general get a multi graph not a
simple graph
so we will denote this multi graph by
configuration model d
now here is the interesting fact uh
which is why i think it is super
interesting to study this
in combinatorics the law of the
configuration model
given that the distribution has
no multiple edges or self loops
conditional law
is same as the uniform distribution
uh
over all possible simple graphs with
given degree sequence
right so if you are trying to if you
someone has given you a degree sequence
if you are trying to generate a graph
uniformly at random
uniform simple graphs what will you do
so you will
try to generate the configuration model
at the first step you might fail you
might get self-loops so you can repeat
it a few times but when you get a simple
graph that simple graph has to be a
uniform sample
from all graphs that's exactly what this
is saying
okay
so
the study of this model goes back to the
70s
bender and canfield and bolobas was
early
interested in
enumeration problems on random regular
graphs
using methods from probability and
that's how they came up with
this uniform choice model or
configuration model but of course around
90s modeling graphs with
general degree sequence became super
important for
different reasons
so the giant component problem also
became interesting the giant component
problem for this configuration model was
studied by mola and reid 95 and 98.
so
are there any questions
since we have yes
if you do this
separate this uh project
how long does it take
is it called it over here
well that depends on your degree
distribution if your degree distribution
is really bad can take a while
but if your degree distribution
has nice properties
i will
show you a nice profit in the next slide
you
if your degree distribution is fast
enough you can
generate it pretty fast
okay obviously this was the super
general model
with general degree distribution and
with general
degree distribution is very difficult
to result
so we will assume certain regularity
conditions which would
seem natural
so for that let
dn be the degree of a uniform vertex
so uh dn is the empirical degree
distribution right so it's a degree of
uniform vertex
and we'll assume that
first of all this
empirical degree distribution converges
to some random variable d in the limit
and tends to infinity okay
intuitive
uh
we just need the proportion of vertices
of each degree
converging to some constant
and the second condition is convergence
of moments so expected degree
expectation of this dn should converge
to expectation d and this expectation d
has to be finite
okay
this
cannot be infinity
so this condition sort of ensures
sparsity because
expectation dn is
1 over n sum over di that's the average
degree and what we are asking is average
degrees converging to a constant
and finally there can be
many trivial situation arise for example
you could have taken
degrees where all degrees are exactly
equal to 2 right
so in that case you will just get a
union of cycles nothing else
so you don't want all the degrees to be
exactly equal to so you assume that
there are some degree two vertices but
there are other vertices as well
okay
so we want to end up with a complex
structure
well this
conditions are usually easy to verify
well if
degrees are generated as iid samples say
from a power or distribution with finite
mean then
these conditions are usually satisfied
so if you look at the literature there
is often another condition that
considers something with the second
moment it considers the second moment of
the degree distribution converges as
well and this kind of
conditions kind of ensures
of the
probability that
after this uniform generation you end up
with a simple graph that probability is
positive right
that
therefore
so conditional on this event the graph
has uniform law right this is just
saying that the conditioning event has
positive probability
uh
therefore if you can
prove some say
concentration results on the
configuration model that considers the
concentration result would carry over
two uniform graphs with given degree
distribution as long as you have this
condition
but again this condition can be ensured
if you have
samples from a parlor distribution with
just finite variance so is this
only for fixed degree
you can allow the degree sequence grow
slowly with them great question so this
expectation is over the uniform choice
so uh
the when you sample the degree
distribution from power law
then you still have to show that one
over n sum over d i converges not the
expectation converges
[Music]
distribution so have a random sequence
so as these converge is the same
probability so that convergence is
condition along the degrees if you have
randomness in the degree sequence you
look at the law
of
this degree of the uniform vertex
conditional understandably the law
converges almost here
uh with respect to the randomness of the
distribution does that answer your
question my question is about this
continuity the lower bound
you have some
is there any result that even for
growing
let's say random regular graphs growing
degree is it possible
that's an interesting question
i don't think that probability is
positive in that case in that case the
probability
so when you have instead so you're
talking about
growing opportunities right which is
actually not covered by this
notion of local convergence we talked
about so that actually jennifer will
talk about that on fire we need a
difference so his theory covers
bounded energy
e to
but then you have to pay attention to
your statement in the configuration
model
extending to one or the failure
probability has to be smaller and better
probably that it's it's not simple right
yeah exactly
you can still use it i guess but it's
more dedicated
because if this is exponentially small
but your concentration is smaller with
the larger exponent
then you can still do what you did
exactly together
a little bit after that's not bad
using
yes
let's
do the local which converges right
so we want to
find how the local neighborhoods behave
in the limit
uh
so initially we start with a random
vertex right and therefore that random
vertex
has degree exactly dn that's by our
assumption
and
dn converges to d by our assumption
right so initially the branching process
approximation will have d manipulation
now
the progeny in the second generation is
a bit more
subtle let's do it
so we are so suppose we are
in the beginning we are trying to
pair this vertex at the root
and this has
are many half edges
but for the rest of the graph let's
divide into different beans
so each bin has so this one has
degree
vertex
all vertices of degree one
this one has all vertices of degree two
degree k
and so on so there will be a bin with
r as well
so in this bin there are say
in r
so in this bin there are
n one vertices and two vertices
in k vertices
and in this bin there will be an r minus
1 vertices right because we have used up
one of the vertices
now
now what suppose uh
this vertex
gets paired
to a vertex of degree n k
then uh
in the next generation so if it has
so how many half edges will be left it
will have k minus one half edges left
right
and those k minus half edges could
explode further and give rise to new
neighbors
so
if
dn star
is the
degree
of this vertex
which
we
fear
the branching process in the or the
exploration
in the pre limit will produce
the n star many
one neighbors in the next generation
now what is the distribution of dn star
minus 1 dn star
well
probability that
the n star
is equal to k
is equal to
well it has to
pair with one of the half edges in this
bin right if it repairs with any one of
the half edges here
then i will get a vertex of degree k
so there are
k in k mini half edges
in the kth
and
the total number of choices is just sum
over l and l
minus 1 because
this half edge cannot pair to itself
right
so
this is approximately equal to
k times p k
over
sum over l
pl
when we know that the proportion of
vertices of degree l converges
is this clear
so i have taken an n tends to infinity
limit here so
in the next step we will already get d
many vertices in the next generation
uh
and probability that d star equals k
is given by just what we deduced
and this distribution is often called
the size biased distribution okay so
branching process produces disturb any
vertices in the next generation
good
now
we can so each of these vertices will be
this
uh will have disturb any one progeny so
this is not like a multi-type branching
process this is the uh
same
type of process as a dossier but the
distribution is different this
distribution is not possible
so expectation is just k minus 1 times
apk by normalizing constant which is the
ratio of the second factorial moment and
the first factorial moment of the
limiting degree distribution
when you did some limit here
you seem to now have used that's a limit
of susceptibility
otherwise
times t minus one so you say if
yes
yeah so there can be
but doesn't it follow from the step
from this condition that empirically
distribution converges
right
so you know that emphatically
distribution converges so the degrees
cannot be too bad in here
so
i think if your degree distribution has
in finite moment then your
the convergence will
be also in coming up
but
problem uh
but
still you can make sense of it if this
means
you can you will get a branching process
within finite mean basically
okay ah
therefore we can talk about survival of
this branching process uh and this is
equal to zeta if this mean
that we computed is more than one
right
therefore we again have the giant
component result so if this parameter
new is less than one
no giant new mode than one a giant has
a
size con concentrating size
and the proportion of vertices
uh
goes to zero
so we just verified
the local week limit right in the last
slide we know the look how the local
exploration looks of course you can
check the second condition as well to
arrive at this but it is
significantly more complicated so i
would like to refer you to see this
paper
the giant in random graphs is almost
local here this condition is verified
for configuration model
but
let me end the discussion about
configuration model with two interesting
cases that you did not see in industry
first of all as christian said mu can be
infinity right
if mu equals infinity for example if you
are sampling your degrees from all or
distribution with infinite variance
then the giant will always exist so you
are in the second region
and number two is it can be that zeta is
exactly equal to one
because for example let's consider the
case where
you have a three regular graph all
degrees are greater than equal to three
then in the exploration all vertices
will have at least
two neighbors in the next generation so
the branching process has to survive
with probability one so this theta
is equal to one that is also covered in
this theorem
uh is there a nice closed form for this
uh a giant size component for different
distributions of degrees like you have
these uh
this guess our distance uh no like more
general case of like uh for example like
a power law that has finite variance as
a function of that power uh it's a
function of uh i guess again you can
calculate it so we we
know how to calculate it right so we
have the branching process we can play
that same trick
uh it survives uh it dies out if none of
if all of its neighbors die out we can
just use that arrive at our six point
equation but i don't remember on top of
my head what that is so i remember you
get actually a two-step process so you
first calculate the survival probability
with this processing decided there
but then the root has a different
distribution because the root has
original distribution so now you have to
but you do the same heuristic so you
express the survival probability of the
root in terms of survival and that will
do with one generation down
and now this one generation now has a
different survival problem but from
there on it's the same
and so you first solve the first and
then insert into the second okay cool
and it keeps again
okay so that's
is or equal to
uh
but that is not covered in that case
mu is
equal to one
it should survive but that is not given
but you don't know how long will it
survive it may so
if you have a network with say
on the degree two vertices you will get
cycles
right so locally
you might get long cycles but
you don't know
the positive fraction of what it is
okay
uh
and for the configuration model today
let's end with dynamically growing
networks
uh so
around 90s there was a huge interest in
dynamically growing networks coming from
biological networks and also invention
of internet right
so
there was a it was a outstanding
challenge in this networks and random
graph theory to come up with models that
grows dynamically and also produces
graphs that are have heterogeneous
degree distribution
and to model that
preferential attachment words model was
produced by bharavasi and albert in 1999
but the ideas that they use also goes
back to yule in 1925. so the idea is
reach get richer
so if you have a vertex in the network
uh which has very high degree let's say
that's a celebrity
if a new vertex arrives they will have
higher chance to connect to the
celebrity compared to someone who are
not celebrities right
so the vertices which has higher degree
they will have higher degrees later as
well
initially they have higher degrees
so uh this model was first studied uh by
bolobus reward and spencer and tusnadi
uh
in the mathematical literature i will
actually mention their result in a short
while but before that let's see their
model
well
new vertices come with many connections
okay every someone comes to the network
they have m edges they can connect to
and
in the beginning you start with a graph
with
start with a single vertex that has m
self loop so that it does not have
degree 0 right and
at time t
vertex vt arrives
and the edges of this vertex vt
are paired sequential
right and after each
pairing the degrees are updated
so the degree depends on the vertex v
the time when the vertex arrives t and
also where are you
in the pairing process e
okay
now the eighth edge connects to a
previous vertex with probability
proportional to
the current degree
and it connects to itself it creates a
self loop with probability
again proportional to degree but there
is a plus one because without that uh
it will never create a sensor
so
connection probability is proportional
to the degree in this model
and at the nth step you have a graph and
each vertex is coming with m connections
so at the end you have nm edges
okay
some
first thoughts if you have
m equals one connection so each vertex
comes with one connection then you get a
tree
and that is called the preferential
attachment tree
but in general you won't get a tree
you set the first one
so now it starts with once well it is a
tree with a loop
the second substep of the second
[Music]
because if that is not the case
initially it has been zero right so it
will never connect to itself okay but
now if m equals one
then you need to modify the law for f
equals one to ten three because it now
has also some chance to produce seven
roots later
yes but i mean yes yes so that later you
if you want to
create the tree you will get rid of one
more
okay ah the way we have defined this
preferential attachment network it is
always connected right it connects to
already uh the connected part in the
network so
we will not think about the question of
giant emergence here again
uh
but the interesting questions are of
course finding degree distributions and
also local neighborhood structures let
me
actually show you what the degree
distribution looks like for this model
uh this this result is due to uh
voluba's rewarded expense and business
so if pkn denotes the proportion of
vertices of degree k
and let's say m is greater than equal to
1
then you have
this convergence so pkn
converges to some pk
uniformly
so you get an asymptotic tail bound in n
which is very precise
and uh
what is pk well
expression of pk involves
ratio of four
involves four gamma functions but if you
simplify everything you will get this
formula pk is like
c times k to the power minus 3
so what are we saying here so it does
not matter what m is
the graph will always be a power law
with exponent three
right in the preferential attachment
model
that's the observation so you get a
graph with power law but not much
flexibility so later there were models
defined where there were biases and in
the preferential attachment model where
you can get general distributions as
well
uh
yeah
so it is for there are variants of the
preferential attachment model where you
get different power laws
right
i'll skip the proof again but
of course i want to at least point you
to the argument so proof uses martingale
arguments
on p if pkn
and
you
do the martingale argument you come up
with the duke martin wheel and also uh
bound the differences of the martingale
use the azuma housing concentration bub
so
azuma of the inequality that's
what
is important in order to prove it
right
we are done with random graphs with a
more realistic features we saw three
models stochastic block model uh
configuration model and preferential
attachment model uh in the stochastic
block model we saw that the local
neighborhoods are poisson branching
processes
uh in configuration model
we had to pair half edges uniformly
given degrees and then the local
neighborhood was size biased
distribution and in preferential
attachment model versus comes
sequentially
and it leads to a power law degree
distribution as we saw
so
these are one of the first models uh to
model this kind of phenomena of course
you can play around with these models to
come up with composing models in your
real world if you have say global
communities or degree heterogeneity you
can come up with
mixed
block models with configuration
right
up next
i will describe the percolation and
epidemics on networks
so percolation is a simple model given a
graph percolation refers to keeping each
edge of the graph independently with
probability p
so at the end you end up with a random
sub graph of the original graph
now
this looks awfully familiar right
because if the original graph was a
complete graph then this is exactly the
endoscopy random graph
however uh
the now the underlying graph can be
pretty general let's say it will be g
now uh we'll be interested in phase
transition again uh for that let's
define the percolation threshold let u
be a uniform vertex
then
i will call uh there are multiple
definitions of percolation threshold but
i will call uh percolation threshold pc
uh on a sequence of graph gn
if
when if p is less than pc then the
random proportion of vertices in random
components converging probability to
zero
proportion of vertices
if for p more than pc
you have a
component that is macroscopic
okay so that's the definition of phase
temperature on uh general sequence of
graphs
and yeah so this holds for all epsilon
positive strictly positive epsilon does
not depend on
so the definition here
wait what is
for setup set of one
second one
take that one this should be thicker one
it would use center first for people
yeah so
uh
first of all there is a typo uh
it should be theta one proportion
and
what i mean here is probability that
cu
more than
say delta this probability
it
so
the regard
yes
this probability goes to one
so there exists a delta such that this
probability goes to one so you have a
component that has linear size with high
problem oh
yeah there is of course the trivial
upper bound
that this proportion is upper bounded by
one so omega and theta are same
i just want to define set of people
sure thank you
okay
now let's see a
relation with
epidemic so
uh remember that a cir infection model
in this model
an infected person spreads infection to
its neighbor independently with
probability p
and after spreading the infection for
one step the person becomes immune to
the disease okay
so that is why it is
first susceptible persons are first
susceptible then they get infected but
after one step they get recovered sir
so link to yesterday's talk that's the
case where the infection time is
constantly equal one
uh the duration of manufacturing is here
just one half step right you can cover
yes yes in general this is a rather
quality but this
is yesterday
okay yeah just let me start recording uh
let me re-emphasize that uh it's
infected person stays infected only for
one step
not two things what's
so the same mechanism actually applied
for spread of information in social
networks uh
speed of computer viruses right so these
were some of the questions that we
started with yesterday
so
what is the relation of this si and
model to epidemics well there is a
coupling between sir model
and the percolation model what is that
suppose the infection starts at some
vertex u where some vertex v
and it can spread
through any edge
so suppose we have a
graph so initially this vertex is
infected
at the second step
it
could or could not spread to its
neighbor
so this vertices the infection does not
spread these vertices the infection does
burn
and so on uh in this
for from this vertex also so after the
first step
the vertex at the root becomes immune in
the next step
also you play the same game
does it look familiar
so this is the exploration process on
the percolating drop right
so
uh
the
spread of infection is same as the
exploration on percolated graph in the
sir model
uh so that
so the final cluster in the percolation
is exactly equal to the final number of
infected vertices starting from v
and if
the component is large then the
infection would spread to a large
population and people in epidemics are
usually interested in this question uh
that is called epidemic threshold
and finding epidemic threshold is same
as finding percolation threshold that
that's what i wanted to convince you now
i will do calculations with percolation
now
this is the general result i'm talking
about
suppose you have any connected graph g
which is finite
any finite connected graph
let lambda 1a denote the largest
eigenvalue
of this then the result of drive ganesh
and masoli shows
the expected component size is less than
equal to square root n
let's pause for a moment and think about
this result
this is remarkably general right so
the graph does not matter the
vertex does not matter
you have if the probability is less than
1 over lambda a
then
the
percolation cluster would be at most
square root n always it does not matter
what graph you are talking about any
finite graph
so
this in in particular says that
your percolation thresholds
would be at least as large as the
inverse of the largest eigenvalue
now we will do a proof of this
on board
so
let's say you try to calculate expected
cluster size
from any vertex v
this is equal to expectation of sum over
say
i
indicated that
not cb
we can ask first expression so this
result does not mean
that the
expected size of the maximum cluster
but i defined it using random vertices
the percolation threshold
okay ah what is what does this notation
mean it means that v and i are in the
same cluster so if you look at v and i
there is a path between them
so this is equal to sum over i
probability that there is a path between
v to i
and
so the path can have a length k so there
is the path of length k
and you can take a uniform
bound over the length of the path so
let's do that
and
i think
i should have less than equal to here
because i am summing over all i
uh
so
and then sum over k probability that
uh
b to i
has
k
so that means that in the percolated
graph you start from v and i
and there will be distinct intermediate
vertices
uh
such that
this thing k minus one many intermediate
vertices v 1 up to
v k minus 1
such that this path exists in our
percolated graph
now
how many
not first of all what is the probability
that any path of length k survives
can anyone tell me
what is the path what is the probability
that any path of length k survives
exactly it's p to the power k
because each of the edges has to be in
percolation cluster it's p to the power
k
ah
and then
oh i should have written the expectation
first
let's do one more step
just to
have our understanding clear so this is
expected
not so this is less than equal to
expected number of paths uh v2
i of
length
a
right
and this expectation is
equal to sum over i
sum over k
p to the power k
and you can take the number of
uh paths
in
the original graph g
paths of
length
so
i think
let's do one step more simplification we
can get an upper bound on the number of
paths in a graph right we can upper
bound the number of paths by number of
walks
and walks can be computed efficiently
for example if you take the adjacency
matrix and take powers of that adjacency
matrix that gives you
works of length k so let's do that
so this is less than equal to sum over i
sum over k
p to the power k
ah
you take a to the power k
ah
v i
we don't have space here
it's like what we had
the expectation of
this is progress
expectation of c u
is less than equal to sum over
i sum over k
p to the power k
a
to the power k
uh
b i
i will now erase this any questions up
to this point
all right so we can simplify that
expression that expression is
uh
equals to so let's write it in a linear
algebra form right so this is equal to
the matrix p to the power k
a to the power k
sum over k is greater than equal to 1
and
you have a sum over i
so on the right you multiply by the all
ones vector on the left you multiply by
the unit vector that has
uh one in the v
place okay
the same thing
now
now we will use our condition p
times lambda 1 over a is less than 1
and if this condition holds the
matrix
power series of matrix is converge
so
this would be
if we transpose
a
inverse one
right
it's just a matrix power series
expansion
well now we can use the cautious word
simply
uh
we if we use the cauchy source
inequality
you would get
this is less than equal to if we
transpose the spectral norm of
this i minus pa matrix and then
the norm of 1
just by the question of inequality
and
this is
so the norm of this is 1 norm of this is
square root n
so we get square root n
and now
if a is a symmetric matrix i minus b a
inverse is a symmetric matrix so the
spectral norm is same as the largest
eigen value of this matrix right lambda
1
uh
i minus p a inverse
and
i can say about the largest eigenvalue
of this matrix so this is equal to
square root n
1 minus p lambda 1
which is
what we wanted to show
right
so
this is less than equal to square root n
times 1 minus p lambda 1 over a for any
connected graph oh
why did we use connectedness
connectedness is important
uh
the connectedness was
used in this step okay
uh if you don't have so connectedness
ensures that
uh
the graph the adjacency matrix
is irreducible uh so first of all the
pattern root is positive
and also you have the power series
expansion
without irreducible matrix it becomes a
bit tricky
all right
so we are done with the proof
and then the natural question is
is
1 over lambda 1 a a good threshold what
kind of graphs are there for which the
inverse of the largest eigenvalue is a
good threshold
it turns out
yes this is true
for dense sequence of graphs and it was
proved by bolova's box chains rewarding
in 2010
so
if you have any sequence of dense graphs
dense graph means proportion of edges
scale quadratically with the number of
vertices for any sequence of dense
graphs
you
can consider percolation on the graph
with probability
c over lambda 1 a
and if you do that as long as c is less
than equal to one you don't have any
giant
uh
and as long as c is more than one uh you
have a joint so if you have a giant the
component size of random vertices stays
bounded away from zero right
so
uh
this is a very general result it holds
for any dense sequence of graphs
now
naturally you might wonder
how about sparse graphs what happens for
sponsors this talk is about sparse class
right
it turns out that inverse of the largest
eigenvalue is quite far from the from
being the right threshold
for any sequence of sparse graphs why
well
so
i will not prove this but
for any connected graph
the largest eigenvalue of the adjacency
matrix is at most
the
maximum
degree which just follows for
ethereum and there is a lower bound also
the lower bound is in terms of average
degree and square root of maximum degree
okay
so what is this saying
so if we have a sparse graph then this
is an order one quantity right but
usually the maximum degree grows if you
have a power law network it grows
polynomial with n
so the inverse of the largest eigenvalue
actually decays polynomially with the
network
on the other hand usually population
thresholds are positive
for example you can
look at simple examples like random
graphs like uh if you apply percolation
on the endoscopy random graph then
that stays on at the end num graph so
you can find when the giant emerges the
population threshold is the inverse
of this lambda parameter don't get
confused with the eigenvalue here this
is coming from induction lambda
for the configuration model under
regularity conditions on the degrees the
percolation
can be percolation threshold can be
shown to be this quantity expectation d
over expectation d minus 1 so if you
have finite variance of the degree
distribution this stays bounded away
from the zero
from z
so yeah the inverse of the largest
eigenvalue is not quite the right thing
to look at when you are considering
percolation threshold or epidemic
thresholds on sparse graphs right that's
what i wanted to convince you
well
for general sparse class what you can do
you can
see the graph percolated graph with the
on given graph as a random graph
and
last time we proved a very general
result like
so if you can show that this percolated
cluster
a percolated graph
is converging locally weekly and it
satisfies this other condition that we
have two component large components
intersect then you can find epidemic
thresholds for sparse graphs
okay
i wanted to
talk there
about percolation and epidemics
but does anyone have any questions
could you say something if you are
if your survivor
time for the entertainment is actually
not such a writer
uh
so what what kind of models are you
thinking about
yesterday we learned right oh right you
just say okay you sort of i i so i the
first process is clear again right so
you have just
essentially what happens you get so you
don't independ because i have
because now i have
a survivor's legs
if i infect you i was more likely to be
infected
so my other neighbors are more likely to
be infected so you get a correlation
which is probably true for spread of
information or misinformation if i'm in
the mood to write for a long time i'm
more likely to and then more unlikely
and so the question and you can write
down the birth process
just sort of
again a simple type first process you
just don't have for some degree
distributions you get some other degrees
and i wonder whether your methods can be
used
so
i have not thought about this previously
but probably this method can still be
used so this is holds for any sequence
of graph that converges locally quickly
so the question is if you can show that
uh the local will convert those almost
surely and also you can if you can
verify
another oriented graph
i i think one may not be the problem i
think two ways
because now you have oriented graphs and
so then
we don't know what the second condition
means
maybe worse to do
a reading group again
yeah
christian i have a question to you and
are very sweet as well
if you look at a particular
this
i distribution like exponential with
intensity lambda then you can
approximate by both of them can you
isn't it just a double correlation there
will be yet another parameter
not only the infection ratio but yet
another population on top of the
population because of this kind of
procrastination by a was on intensity
london or another
yeah
still kind of uh for me because i'm from
a discrete
world it seems like
maybe one can
put kind of another force on club which
means i twist my intensity
we get another parameter
yeah
so in the last 15 minutes uh
let me finally uh conclude with a very
fascinating topic uh
in random graph theory
and here the convergence of component
sizes is shown using convergence of
stochastic processes okay so again i
just want to give you the overview of
this technique and this technique is due
to aldous in 97
well
let's circle back to it
right so we know what happens at lambda
less than one
we know
what happens at lambda more than one
what happens at lambda equals to one
what happens in between
well uh
in the original paper of it doshini uh
it was said that
the largest component has size like
square n to the power two third but
something really
very interesting happens at lambda
equals 1 which is different than both of
the other regimes
first of all if you look at all the
components
all the components have size of order n
to the power two third okay all the
ordered components so largest component
second largest components and so on they
have size n to the power two third
and number two
is the limit of the descaled component
sizes
are non-degenerate random variables it
is not you don't get concentration like
the giant or in the sub critical basis
you get a very
different distributions of the component
sizes here
and this was
proved by alders in 97
so the theorem says
if lambda equals 1 then if you rescale
the component sizes look at it as a
vector that converges in distribution to
a non-degenerate random variable well
you are talking about convergence of
infinite sequences uh you have to be
careful about topology so
this converges in l2
right
so the description of x will become
clear soon but
the thing is even if you
don't care about what happens at the
criticality i i think this technique is
fascinating you should care about that
okay
help us prove something more right yes
definitely but i just want to explain
yeah yeah definitely but i just want to
show the technique
okay the basic idea is to explore the
graph and encode the graph in terms of
component sizes
inco encode the component sizes in terms
of a walk
so this work is not the walks on graph
so these walls are like random box okay
so
explore the graph and encode component
sizes in terms of a walk
and
then
take the scaling limit of the box
and
the idea is to recover the scaling limit
of the component sizes from this
limiting process that we get
okay
let me show you one
further step so let's say we are doing
this exploration again but with the
exploration we can keep track of this
walk which at each step adds
some new children
minus one
minus one because at each step uh we are
exploring one vertex right so we have to
remove that vertex in the work
so you keep on going like that
and eventually you finish
exploring the component
and i claim that the first component is
explored when this walk hits minus one
why is that well
so there there is a one extra minus one
coming up in the first that's why there
is minus one so at the beginning of each
compo
exploration of each component you get an
additional minus one in the rest of the
times you all always
get explode vertices right so you take
the minus one because of the explode
vertices
so the whole point
here is if you look at the walk
and look at the heating time to minus
one that should give you the component
size if you look at the heating time to
minus 2 that will be your second
component size and so on
so even if you throw away all the graph
and just look at this walk we can tell
what the component sizes are that's what
i meant when i said explore the graph
and encode the component sizes in terms
of the work
i have not said that's coming up in the
next slide
any other questions
yeah just to clarify so these
each time you get a negative one it's
like one of the sort of um
one of the descendant populations dying
out and you're just counting yeah right
so at least
you are getting one so you have active
vertices which have not been explored so
that's that you uh put one of them uh in
the exposure but the thing is at the
beginning of each component side you
have an additional point
that's why you get this
right
so component sizes are so this kind of
things are called excursion lengths of
the testing processes
okay
and i just first showed
that if you rescale the component sizes
so if you rescale the time by including
about
two thirds and the space by 10 to the
power one third
then this rescaled process
converges to a brownian motion but not a
brownian motion that has a negative
parabolic drift so if you look at the
process it will look something like this
so
you have the walks right
it's minus one this is the component
size 1
minus 2 with the component size 2 and so
on if you take the limit
you will end up with a picture like this
bad drawing of a diffusion
so
these are now our limiting component
size in some sense so i
sort of will skip a lot of calculations
but everything can be made precise so
the whole idea is that if you can show
the limit of exploration processes you
know the component sizes are
rescaled by
n to the power two third here
yeah
you know but you have an excursion which
goes far down and that
would that
be very unlikely
so there is a negative grip
why don't you restart your exploration
essentially i mean the minus one becomes
actually a zero
yeah so you can so what you're talking
about that's looking at the reflected
process i did not define the reflected
process
i just looked at the exploration process
if you reflect the process at zero then
you will get one
so you say serum is true for both the
reflective process ends and not with it
i mean originally it is proved i mean
reflected processes uh continuous
function on the hand let's space so if
you can prove it for the original
process you can do it for the reflected
process
and also the
excursion length is a continuous
function on the cadmium space if you
have some regular conditions
so you can from that you can reduce
component services
okay so i just skipped like uh
probably 10 intermediate results but
sort of wanted to give you an id
so the excursion length of this process
will give us the
rescaled component sizes where component
sizes have to be scaled by n to the
power two third because time was scaled
by n to the power 2 3 right
and our time indicated
the exploration of components
so this implies the
rescale component sizes ordered
converging distribution
to
ordered excursion length of these
stochastic processes that you get
okay so everything depends on whether
you can prove
this thing but this is not a very nicely
behaved object usually if you have
random walks you can use uh functional
uh
central limit theorem to prove results
like it converges to brownian motion but
in this case uh
you can
so in this case these are not like
simple random works these are
martingales so you can use something
called a martingale functional central
limit theorem in order to arrive at this
result
if you don't reflect the process
so the excursions are defined in a way
that whenever you uh
get back to the previous minima
that's your excursion
you're effectively doing the respected
yeah exactly nice okay so
yeah yeah so the reflector i mean the
the minimum process is always degrading
when it is the minimum that's when you
have explore the compound
right
so uh this is a technique
but uh what why should you so first
revisit me the method so we explore the
graph and encode component sizes in
terms of a walk
and take scaling limits
of the
work and
sort of recover the limits of the
component sizes from the limiting causes
that was the whole idea okay in this
case you got this uh
very nice downian motion blah blah blah
but
in general you can also do the same
technique
for super critical graphs right so in
when you are exploring supercritical
graphs if you rescale properly
the limit of the random graphs
limit of the exploration process would
look something like this
because the component size converges and
the exploration process also
concentrates around a deterministic
curve and this hitting time will give
you the size of the giant component
right
and actually this method was applied by
janssen and loop jack
for configuration models you can check
out that paper
right
summary we are at the end so
we considered percolation and epidemics
and we saw that percolation can be
coupled to the sir epidemics
then uh
we showed that
expected cluster size is like square
root n
whatever be your graph
uh
but then for dense graphs this
is the right threshold
okay
however sparse graphs it's not
that's why uh studying epidemics on
sparse graphs
uh completely separately super
interesting
and the second
part we
learned about a method called
exploration process convergence and use
it to find non-degenerate scaling limits
of component sizes at ethernet at lambda
equals one
so for further reading you can look at
these references most of the things i
have covered
are in this book in this book of random
graphs and complex networks
for percolation and epidemics you can
look at this paper for critical behavior
aldous
proves a lot of things in that paper
they look at critical window and
evolution of processes over the critical
window like convergence to something
called a multiplicative coalescent so
if you are interested in fascinating
stochastic objects feel free to look
them up
and yeah so you can also
look at my doctoral thesis and
in chapter one there is a survey on
what happens near the criticality
what happens near the criticality for
many graph models so you can look at the
cell
okay so
yeah uh
my goal was kind of to introduce you to
many of these different concepts and
also the techniques that we use usually
in random graph theory so hopefully
you enjoyed it and learned something
please let me know if you have any
questions or i am here for the whole
semester so we can always grab a coffee
right
thank you very much that was a beautiful
sequence of two talks
do you have any more questions
yes
so you said in your dissertation you did
the
in your description you studies critical
behavior
where for graphs with the prescribed
degrees let's say so in the paper molloy
and reid i don't think that they could
determine the correct width of the
critical window
can you do something
so so we what we show is that if you
look at the graphs with given degrees
then as long as you have a finite third
movement condition on the degree
distribution you get the same limit as
the induction
so there
yes and over the whole window so you get
the whole per multiplication process yes
yes yes yes so my question was indeed
the correct width of the window like in
the editorial we know that this should
be if you parameterize it by your
parameter laminar then it should be
width of n to the one third yeah minus
one third yes depending on how you see
the things
right
so it is lambda times n to the power
minus one third for reduction however if
you don't have finite third moment it's
a different thing
with depends on the degree distribution
yeah that's what i thought
thank you very much
further questions
i could just say it
so
i know this is just an introduction i
really like this um in general if you
have a little bit of dependence in any
sense does does
do some of these techniques carry over
or is it kind of right so
they do
for example if you are doing say
configuration model
the edge connections are not independent
but you can apply this exploration
process technique still
but uh
the
con i mean verifying things like
martingale convergence theorem
functional
those are
quite difficult well let me
sort of give an example so what if it
did the pots model near q equals one but
q is not exactly one so they have a
small perturbation of being independent
but you
sort of
multiply clusters by q to the number of
clusters and q is almost one but not
quite so you have a small perturbation
of independent population
do you have results like these
i don't exactly say the model you think
if if you can define it
of course take your favorite model like
say the configuration model
don't do independent percolation do
calculation on it that where the
probability of seeing a configuration is
multiplied by q to the number of
clusters okay and q is not one it's one
plus epsilon
i think i don't know so that would
introduce some interaction right so
so there are many
all you could have that at your vertex
maybe it's more likely to have three
edges it's not just p to the power
of i mean it's not binomial and p but
it's some other distribution of the
degrees
so you get some
small so in that
but i mean there are many orders where
you would have dependent population
and the question is that maybe it would
be super interesting if i could do
something like that
yes i i mean on top of my head i
definitely don't know how to prove
scaling limit of the expiration process
it is already shown in the literature
but definitely
talk about it so the physicist would say
two is smaller than four
should hold dry oil in two dimensions
maybe at least then it's confirmed
the same kind of
limits or i have no idea okay
okay
good
thank you all and
so
i still